Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
has warned that war is coming to Russia
after three drones were downed over
Moscow the Russian defense Ministry
blamed Keith for that attack drones have
reached the heart of the Russian capital
in recent months though they've not
caused major damage
Russian aggression has gone bankrupt on
the battlefield today is the 522nd day
of the so-called special military
operation which the Russian leadership
expected to last for a week or two
Ukraine is getting stronger gradually
the war is returning to the territory of
Russia to its symbolic centers and
military bases and this is an inevitable
natural and absolutely Fair process
and Russia says that Ukraine has
launched another drone strike on its
soil the attack targeted a police
building in a district in briansk region
no injuries have so far been reported so
we will go to Julia shop of Oliver in
Moscow for reporting on that in just a
moment though let's begin right now with
step Vos in Step you're in Ukraine let's
start with these comments by the
Ukrainian president what do you read
into what zielinski said that he now
almost officially supports attacks on
Russian soil
well these are very interesting comments
indeed and it could be hinting at a new
strategy from the side of Ukraine in
which it wants to involve basically the
Russian population more into this war
because until now uh Russia's population
hasn't felt much of the war and these
drone attacks in Moscow and the
political and economic economical heart
of Russia could of course put pressure
from the population the Russian
population on President Putin but this
is so far of course pure speculation he
hasn't said anything like that but this
is what you could read into it they have
also not officially claimed these
attacks on Moscow on Sunday but while
Russia's population is not feeling much
of the war here in Ukraine of course
it's a completely different story every
day the Ukrainian population feels the
results of the war they are attacks
nearly every day and as we speak just
before we went on air there was an
attack in Cleveland where also a
residential building has been hit again
we have not heard of any casualties
there but the damage is really
significant and also in her son we have
heard this uh one dad and two injured of
also an attack early this morning and
here in khakif where we are today last
night there were two hits as well one in
the city and the warehouse one person
got injured and one outside of the city
close to the Russian border where a
private house was hit
all right step stand by for us for a
moment please I want to go to Yulia
who's in Moscow and talk about the
ripple effect of all of this on the
Russian side of the Border first yoyo
what do you know on the attacks in
briansk
yes according into the Russian side a
Ukrainian drone struck a police station
with no casualties there their attack
took place in the Border briansk region
as you say so basically that's the
official information we have so people
are getting used to wake up to the news
like that unfortunately Also earlier on
today a UAV crashed in a farm near
taganrog in the southern Russia and
according to local residents a car
called fire and one of the houses was
damaged and there are also reports that
the locals had to cope with the
consequences of that tag themselves they
had to extinguish the Flames themselves
then the emergency workers and
firefighters joined them and no
casualties were reported there but some
people were panicking though that's
according to to the reports Julia tell
me a little bit more about whether all
of this is moving the needle for the
Russian public in any significant way
because drone attacks yesterday on the
capital I know there wasn't that much
damage but symbolically really
significant those pictures carry weight
today more drone attacks in briansk
zelenski warning that the war is coming
to Russia I wonder if this moves the
needle for the Russian public
yeah that's right of course Russia is
big and very diverse but at the level of
anxiety is growing of course as people
are worried about a possible new round
of mobilization due to lengthening the
draft age and the country about regular
drone attacks on the border regions and
even on Moscow as like yesterday at the
same time people some people don't even
care especially those who watch Russian
TV because most channels simply ignore
the news about their attacks on the
Moscow City yesterday on July the 30th
and Russian President Vladimir Putin was
informed about the Drone attack on the
Moscow region and Moscow but at the same
time he participated in the Navy parade
in Saint Petersburg hosting several
African leaders so basically it's a
signal for most people it's just
business as usual okay that's all really
interesting context business as usual in
that case let me take it back thank
thank you Julia let me take it back to
step who's in harkiv in Ukraine step you
were telling us just a moment ago
of course it's not business unusual for
ukrainia as usual for ukrainians because
their their life has been changed in
very deep ways they are experiencing war
on a day-to-day basis and I understand
there have been heavy attacks near where
you are tell us about those
yeah so besides all these air attacks
the the war on the ground is ongoing and
this counteroffensive that Ukraine
started over a month ago is still
intensifying what we are looking at here
is two different front lines one in the
South where Ukraine has they have made
some advances but also here close to
khakif in the Northeast on Sunday uh the
deputy defense minister announced really
heavy fighting here in this area Russian
forces have really been pushing hard she
said but Ukraine has managed to
recapture those positions we can't
independently confirm this but this is
coming from the Ukrainian government so
the the counter offenses is really uh
picking up I have to say so there's
really heavy fighting here we don't hear
much about any casualties or how exactly
these advances are going but this is
definitely happening right now nice step
Boston reporting from Hakeem thank you
very much